let me give you one other example
there's a brother-in-law this is a real
case and he learns this is a long time
ago a couple of hundred years ago he
learns that his sister's brother has
died this is down in Alabama and there
she is living in not too good
circumstances in a not very nice area
with her two children so he's feeling
kind of generous and he says you know I
have an extra house on my farm if you
sell the dump you're living in and move
here I'll let you have this house for
free because I feel bad about you living
in those circumstances so she sells the
house she sells it at a loss she pulls
up stakes spends a certain amount of
money moving and moves into this house
that her brother-in-law has set aside
for her and her children but I told you
it's a sad story after a year or so the
brother-in-law is not feeling so
generous anymore
and maybe he figures he doesn't like
this woman all that much the kids he
doesn't like having them nearby at all
so he makes the move out of this house
which belongs to him and moving to
something much less desirable and then
after a little while later he throws
them out of that - can the sister-in-law
sue
[Music]